[Music]
it's all myself around the world now you
might think before we even begin there's
something a bit suspicious about their
very idea because you know people are
people as we as we know and people other
people all around the world so you know
when everyone kind of suggests that you
know the self means completely different
things in in different cultures that
we've got reasons to be suspicious if
you've traveled and you've been to East
Asia for example you may have met
someone there and you know you think
they were recognizably human beings like
yourself so so what's the difference I
think there are differences in how both
cultures and philosophies conceive of
the self and these things are very
interestingly related I should say the
background to this the reason I'm
talking about is I wrote a book on
global philosophy and of course it's
sort of a huge subject so I couldn't
attempt to become an expert on this and
then write the book I think there's no
one in the world is an expert on all the
world's philosophies so I approached it
kind of like a philosophical journalist
in a sense that I spoke to a lot of
experts in fields and in trying to
synthesize it and bring it together and
in Richard II my idea was I was just
interested in philosophy but then a
question arose in my mind which is if
you learn something about the
philosophical tradition of a culture do
you learn anything about that culture
itself as it is today and the experts I
spoke to would all unanimously said that
was true and I think this is right so
when I talk about the philosophy of the
self I'm talking not just about the
philosophy of the self I'm thinking
about how concepts of self function in
non-western cultures now go back to my
skeptical point though aren't people
people everywhere around the world this
is true there's this guy Tom kosuna so
comparative philosopher who works on
Japanese philosophy and he said one of
the single most useful things that I
read and when I was researching this
book he said the problem is when people
talk about East West etc etc they too
often kind of say
in the East they do this in the West
they do that as though it was like an
either or binary kind of choice he says
that's the wrong way of looking at it
the right way of looking at it is and
this is pretty much only a slight
paraphrase is the what's foreground in
one culture is background in another and
vice versa
so it is true that everywhere around the
world human beings are human beings
selves have certain aspects but in
different cultures and also different
philosophies different aspects of these
cells are given greater emphasis and
some are given less emphasis and that
actually does affect the way we feel
about ourselves and the way we relate to
others now of course there are lots of
fine-grain differences all around the
world all what I'm going to try and set
out in this short talk today is what
that's often a core difference is in the
sense of core diversity what gets
emphasized in Western cultures and
morges emphasized actually I'm saying
pretty much all non-western cultures but
I'm only going to talk really about East
Asia and in particular Japan so let's
start off by checking the stereotype of
the self in Japan this is a famous
shopping district in Japan where there's
this famous pedestrian crossing and you
know from a vantage point like this what
you see is you see huge masses of people
waiting for the lights to change the
lights then change and then there's this
huge crossing of people but very very
orderly very organized it looks like
kind of you know ants insects herds is
be alert these are actually slightly
dehumanizing words so I am aware of that
and people see the pictures of this they
also see pictures of people on the
famously overcrowded Tokyo underground
again before going on on mass and the
impression I think people get is that
this needs a kind of conformist cultures
in which is all about the group and it's
not about the individual and it's about
the absence of individuality basically
people subsume their identity into that
of the group and conform and go along
with me
I want to try and explain this by giving
a concrete example i-i've been reading
about concepts of self and
understandings of self in Japan and I've
speak to Japanese philosophers and I was
leaving Japan on a plane and I noticed
that a lot of the passages were Japanese
and there lot of birds let's use the
same in-flight movie right which I
didn't recognize so I thought this is
interesting what is this film everyone's
watching I'll watch it SID
and I'm really glad I did because in
this film it kind of made concrete to me
what was going on with these concepts of
self in the films so this film was
called orange it was in its opening
weekend that number one in a box office
in Japan it was based on a manga and it
was a teen romance of teenage romance
okay but it certainly was very
importantly different from most Western
teenage romances particularly Hollywood
ones not only because the plot involves
two suicides which is suicide doesn't
tend to feature a lot in teenage
romances in in in Western the traditions
um but that was that was only that
wasn't actually the most interesting
difference the most interesting
difference was this though here we have
a picture a scene from the film and if
you can't see the point of a piece to
this is this of the love interest this
couple it's a story about them but it
but these two people the people who you
know the film is all about them getting
together in many respects they are only
seen alone in the film twice I think is
twice you know I wasn't counting exactly
the desert no for handful of times now
it's not cuz there's a taboo you might
think well in some continental foods
again showing young people alone and
sexually dangerous no they were shown
alone but they weren't shown alone a lot
now why not and the answer was the whole
development of this bomb was showing how
this relationship between the key couple
was only only kind of could emerge and
made sense within the relationship of a
whole friendship group right the couple
one isolated from that broader social
if you think about most romantic films
that you see in the coming out of
Britain and America and even I think you
know that continental Europe - um what's
quite striking about them is that itself
did you you keep so much the time its
focus on just this couple it's almost
like there isn't a world outside you
know I mean they pretend to be a typical
scene where they will meet a friend over
copies talk personally and very very
briefly but this friendly until it
disappears or something this such a
focus on over that couple in this film
it's not like that at all the couple
only exists in a context of relationship
in this scene that the kind of
dependencies made heavy handedly
because that they are carrying the crash
map for a school sports day and their
friends emerge and they say we'll help
you carry the load and this is kind of
metaphorical so there's clearly a kind
of message being put over here if it
goes really deeper than that that this
has a complicated plot involving time
travel okay really yeah and what happens
is this boy he's due from the area he
comes to the school and he's troubled
and his mother kills himself she can't
go and then he kills himself right and
that and this is what has happened this
girl grows up she marries I think him
and they have a child and they're very
happy right I mean I'm reconstructing
the timeline a bit more linearly than
film but that's what happens but somehow
unexplained in the film as adults they
discover a way of sending a message back
in time which has the opportunity to
open up an alternative future in which
something else happens right now there
are two really important things about
this the flash thing is that having
discovers these these kids they feel
deeply responsible for the death of this
boy it was a suicide he killed himself
but they kind of recognize that that
suicide was partly their failure to
write and that's really really clear and
evident and and and again that's that's
a feeling that certainly people can have
in Western cultures that we talked about
how we let people down suicides etc etc
but I don't think we perhaps feel it as
strongly in cultures where the
interrelations between
people have more emphasis in here it's a
very obvious thing to them the boy
killed himself that means there was a
failure of the group that's one of the
reasons why they're so keen to rectify
but the other interesting point is of
course if they succeed in keeping this
boy alive right then he's not going to
go and and and she's not gonna end up
marrying him she's gonna marry him so
but the husband goes along with this the
husband conspires in the plot which
makes sure that his wife in an alternate
future gets a better partner now that is
a very kind of social way of thinking
about relationships right now I thought
this this film was was was brilliant it
really kind of did show against but I
said earlier about the
foreground/background thing the
foregrounding in in the Western cultures
that the individual and in a romances
the couple is the small small units the
discrete units the central units in here
there are individual characters the
story is about them but everything
always takes place and only makes sense
within the broader connections people
have with each other and one of the
important things to note about this is
this is does not suggest the lack of
individuality the slide I showed at the
beginning I think the stereotype is is
conformity uniformity people being the
same actually it's very evident in this
film that is absolutely not the case
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas